[Música]
hola bienvenidos a revista digital donde
abordamos los temas más importantes del
ciberespacio las redes sociales y los
medios de comunicación de américa latina
y el mundo
ante la situación de kobe 19 ahora
trabajamos desde casa batalla por la
legitimidad de las elecciones en eeuu ni
las grandes cadenas de televisión ni las
redes sociales están dejando pasar
desapercibidos las infundadas
acusaciones del presidente de donald
trump sobre un fraude de los comicios
una situación que atiza la ya complicada
relación del mandatario con estas
grandes compañías que dicen ambas partes
empezamos cuatro días después de las
elecciones y cuando los medios de
comunicación estadounidenses anunciaban
que joe biden tenía los votos necesarios
para ganar la presidencia un furioso
donald trump tuiteaba lo siguiente
desde cuando los relevantes medios de
comunicación deciden quién será nuestro
próximo presidente desde el día 1 el
presidente se mostró optimista frente a
las elecciones pero varias horas después
el mapa electoral fue tornándose azul a
favor de yo bailar en estados clave para
asegurar la casa blanca entre ellos
michigan y wisconsin la ira del
mandatario no se hizo esperar e inició
una escalada verbal contra el proceso
electoral sin ningún fundamento señalaba
un intento de fraude conllevó sus
denuncias a la televisión nacional cnn y
su favorito foxnews continuaron con la
alocución y al final aclararon que no
existe prueba de ello pero otras grandes
cadenas como babies y civiles en bici y
ms en bici fueron más allá e
interrumpieron al mandatario tan sólo
minutos después de haber empezado a
transmitir sus declaraciones
tenemos que interrumpir aquí porque el
presidente hizo una serie de
declaraciones falsas incluida la idea de
que han habido votaciones fraudulentas
días después foxnews interrumpió a la
secretaria de prensa de la casa blanca
quien decía que hubo votos ilegales una
situación que evidencia cuán serios
están tomando este tema a las grandes
cadenas de televisión
creo que tenemos que dejar muy claro que
está acusando a la otra parte de dar la
bienvenida al fraude y dar la bienvenida
al voto ilegal a menos que tenga más
detalles para respaldar eso no puedo
seguir mostrándoles esto con buen ánimo
ahora respondiendo a la pregunta de
trump sobre si los medios deben escoger
al presidente claro que no es así pero
esto sí que han tenido un rol clave
desde 1848 según recuerda la agencia
associated press a diferencia de otros
países eeuu no tiene una autoridad
nacional electoral que cuente los votos
y anuncia el ganador de las elecciones
presidenciales sino que cada estado es
responsable de ello eso siempre señala
que los medios fueron los únicos
dispuestos a tabular las elecciones en
todos los estados y así determinar con
rapidez quién se perfila como el nuevo
mandatario
nosotros las grandes cadenas de
televisión estuvieron vigilando los
discursos que trataban de poner en duda
la integridad de las elecciones así es
como luce la cuenta del presidente de
donald trump en twitter decenas de sus
tweets en los que alegaba fraude o se
proclamaba como ganador fueron
escondidos o verificados por la misma
plataforma advirtiendo que parte o todo
el contenido allí publicado puede ser
engañoso esto hace parte de la política
anunciada por twitter previendo que
trump reclamara falsamente una victoria
o desestimar a la votación por correo
que este año registró niveles récord
debido a la pandemia de kobe 19
este tipo de trinos representan una
infracción a las reglas de tweeter sobre
la política de integridad cívica y se
castiga con sanciones que van desde la
eliminación del tuit hasta la suspensión
permanente de la cuenta
esto incluye pero no se limita a
reclamos disputados que podrían socavar
la fe en el proceso en sí como
información no verificada sobre
manipulación electoral manipulación de
boletas recuento de votos o
certificación de resultados electorales
y reclamar la victoria antes de que se
certifique en los resultados de las
elecciones sin embargo por tratarse de
un líder mundial en funciones twitter
sólo se limita a etiquetar los extremos
consideramos que el contenido es de
interés público si contribuyen
directamente a la comprensión oa la
discusión de un asunto de interés
público esto significa que cuando
donación deje la presidencia sus trinos
ya no serán de interés público perderá
dicho privilegio y de continuar con las
infracciones podría ser removido de la
plataforma que ha sido su canal de
comunicación favorito se espera que son
de género la casa blanca y por
complicada que haya sido su relación con
los medios de comunicación éstos ya
hablan de lo que sería la industria sin
el presidente
un análisis en el 'new york times'
predice que las compañías de medios
tradicionales incluidas mc en bici y the
times enfrentan el posible final del
llamado trump refiriéndose al aumento en
el interés por las noticias sobre el
polémico mandatario el semanario
estadounidense edwin dice que para la
mayoría de los editores de grandes
medios la cobertura sin aliento del
presidente ha servido como una inyección
adictiva en el brazo para los negocios
digitales un artículo de la revista
forbes titula este es el final de una
era para los medios de comunicación de
eeuu dice que de alguna manera la
elección del presidente truman 2016 fue
una bendición para los editores de
noticias y agrega aquí estaba la
ascensión a la oficina más poderosa del
mundo por parte de un candidato como
ningún otro y los lectores estaban
hambrientos de información que les
ayudarán a darle sentido a todo hasta
aquí revista digital recuerde que si
quiere repetir esta otra emisión de
nuestro programa lo puede hacer a través
de nuestra página web www punto tras 24
punto com
[Música]